hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brown
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD tutorial and which I'll be teaching
you guys how to use YouTube tags so you
guys are probably wondering why someone
would do a tutorial on tagging a YouTube
video it's fairly obvious say you can
just input the tags and whenever someone
searches for the tags they will find all
the videos with that in their tags
pretty simple but these are actually
tags that I have here that will change
your YouTube video and if you've already
seen these or use these let me know what
your experience has been with them
because I want to you know I want to
know what which one you like the best
but obviously this fourth one here I'm
going to show you guys in a minute is
one that's going to be very important
for my future videos so anyway I want to
ask you guys a question about that one
when we get there either way the first
one is whitey crop equals 16 by 9
putting this in your tags will pretty
much zoom in and cut off the top and
bottom slices of your YouTube of your
YouTube video so if you have 4 by 3
content I've pretty much cut this
notepad document down to 4 by 3 aspect
ratio I'm gonna add an annotation here
to spot like the 4 by 3 area so that's
what it's going to look like it's gonna
cut off the top and bottom half of your
video which is kind of not necessary for
most YouTube videos if you're doing a
tutorial you might want to reconsider
that however the second one is
yt:stretch equals 16 by 9 which is
actually a better option for you
tutorial makers however I did my mkbhd
update 2.3 using the stretch annotation
and it definitely didn't look right my
square my Square watermark was actually
a rectangle everything was stretched out
and you really don't need to use this
unless you really really want to fill up
the widescreen of the YouTube you know
the widescreen YouTube player so this
will stretch your 4 by 3 content pretty
much lengthwise now the last thing the
third one here is yt:stretch equals 4 by
3 this will fix 720 by 480 content
that's the wrong aspect ratio
it'll scale it into four by three so you
won't have those weird sized window
boxing it'll look the same as a regular
four by three video and it'll kind of
stretch it to fix instead of 640 by 480
which is kind of widescreen
but the wrong aspect ratio it'll stretch
it to four by three I've never really
had to use that one the last and most
important tag I want to talk about is
why t : quality equals high and this
will actually set your video to default
stream in high quality the same as
adding and fmt equals 18 to the end of
the URL now as you guys know I produce
all of my videos all of my tutorials and
hardware unboxings and reviews in
high-definition
however a lot of people's streams
internet connections and etc can't
really handle the high-definition so my
question to you guys which I want you to
comment about is should I actually add
that stream add that tag to the end of
all my videos so that you guys always
just wash in HQ by default now it'll
obviously blow it up to the the larger
than normal HQ player but it'll still be
it'll be less than high-definition but
it'll be good quality and good enough
for you guys to see so I'm actually
going to do that to this tutorial so you
guys can see what it's like when I add
that to the end it'll automatically
stream in HQ when it's available and
that is basically it so thank you guys
for watching this stream or a little a
tag tutorial and again leave your
comments whether you want me to set that
tag so that all my videos automatically
go ahead and play in HQ instead of HD I
know a lot of your computers or Internet
connections can't handle that anyway
thank you for watching this tutorial and
I'll catch you guys in the next video
peace
you